Please welcome Matthew Dicks to the stage.
Thank you.
I'm standing on the
playground behind my school.
It's recess duty.
When my son was very little, he
asked me, Is recess duty like duty?
Like poop?
And I said, yeah, actually,
it is just like that.
And I sent him away.
I am sure that conversation
created enormous problems for
him at some point in his life.
But it was an accurate
description of recess duty.
I waste my precious time putting
band aids on cuts that are not cuts,
pretending to listen to stories about
cousins birthday parties, and telling
mean children that they have no one
to play with because they are mean.
And so I'm standing there doing all
of these things when I hear these four
words that strike fear into my heart.
Never have I ever.
And I look over and I see three of
my students, ten year old girls,
on the sidewalk, and apparently
they are playing this game.
So now I am running, because I
have played Never Have I Ever.
I understand the dynamics of this game.
This is not a benevolent game where we
acquire knowledge about our friends.
This is social combat.
This is, we extract information from
foolish children and then we sharpen
it and we stab them with it later on.
So I'm running over, like, 1985,
Jimbo Power's birthday party.
Melissa says, Matt, never
have you ever kissed someone?
And immediately I have to
figure out Do I tell the truth?
Basically what I'm wondering
is, is everyone else in
this room kissed somebody?
Because if so, now I have to lie and
say yes, and I have to prepare myself
for the questions that will come, which
will undoubtedly be, Who did you kiss?
And since no one has ever kissed me in
my school, and probably never will, I
have to make up a story about the time my
parents took me to the far flung land of
Pawtucket, Rhode Island or Woburn and I
was in a candy store and I had a tryst by
a licorice stand with a girl Story that
did not work a kid once asked me never
have you ever gone to third base and I
knew It wasn't about baseball, but that
is all I knew about that question So I am
running to these girls and as I get close
I hear one of them say Never have I ever
gone to bed without brushing my teeth.
And I sort of grind to a halt.
Because this is not 1985 Sex
and Drugs, Never Have I Ever.
This is like Paw Patrol,
Never Have I Ever.
It's fine.
There's nothing wrong here.
And as I turn to walk away,
the girls say, Mr. Dicks, you
want to play Never Have I Ever?
And they explain to me That
their game's a competition.
They stand on the sidewalk and if
you've never ever done something,
you take a step forward and whoever
gets to the bench first wins.
And now I'm all in because
I love competition.
I love to crush small children in games
that are utterly meaningless so I can
feel better about myself as a human being.
So I'm standing there on the line with
the girls and the first girl says,
Never have I ever climbed a mountain.
And all three of them step forward.
I'm like, are you kidding me?
You're ten and you've
never gone up a mountain?
Like, no lie, when I'm twelve I
get lost in the white mountains
of New Hampshire for two days.
And nobody cares, including me.
They've never climbed a mountain before?
The next girl says, Never have I ever
gone to bed without a night light on.
And I think, Oh my god,
lady, don't say that.
Cause we're all gonna
make fun of you for it.
Oh my God, I'm the only one who's
going to make fun of her for this.
Like, this group of children
that I'm taking care of,
they're so different than I was.
Like, they've taken all their
daggers and put them away.
They're sweet, they're accepting.
It's not all good.
No, no, it's not all good.
Like, they, this generation of children
can't get ten feet from a water bottle
without being triggered in some way.
They're the most hydrated group of
kids I've ever met in my entire life.
It is a nightmare.
They can't go through my math
lessons without a squishy
thing or a stuffed animal.
I had a girl last week in my math lesson
with a blanket wrapped around her.
I said, what's up with the blanket?
She said, it makes me happy during math.
I said, math isn't happy.
It's awful.
It's hard.
It's onerous.
I would have loved to have a water
bottle and a, and a blanket and a stuffed
animal during math when I was a kid.
All I had was angst and despair.
It made me who I am.
I can't stand these kids.
And I'm losing the game because I have
done everything and they've done nothing,
so they're nine steps ahead of me.
And then the tallest girl says, Never
have I ever met my father's expectations.
And I think, that is nonsense,
because I know your fathers.
They're all fine men.
What are you talking about?
And one of the girls says, Well, I'm a
swimmer, and when I get a PR in the pool
and I come out, my dad's happy for me.
But then he says, But just imagine how
much better you could have been if you
had nailed the kick turn on the third lap.
And the next girl says, Well, I mastered
my multiplication facts last month, and
when I came home to my dad, he said,
That's great, but why didn't you do it
in October when you were supposed to?
And the third one says, My dad always
tells me how I can be better, and
I know he does it because he loves
me, but it never feels like love.
And now I'm panicking.
I'm thinking what about my
children, Charlie and Clara?
Have I ever told them that
they've met my expectations?
They never have.
I mean, they don't even come close.
Like, but how have I at least
fooled them into believing that they
occasionally meet my expectations?
And so as I'm panicking about
this situation, the tall girl
says, Mr. Dicks, have you ever
met your father's expectations?
And I catch for a minute.
I don't know what to say.
But then I know exactly what to say
because I've been working with kids for
25 years as a teacher and I know they're,
they're more capable than we all know.
And so I tell her, I say, my father left
when I was seven and he never came back.
And so I don't think he ever
had expectations for me.
And three hands reach out and they
grab my wrist and they pull me forward.
And that girl says,
That counts, Mr. Dicks.
And then she tells me, I'm sorry your
father abandoned you when you were a kid.
And it is crazy, but from the age
of 7 to 52, I have basically been
waiting for my father to come back.
And it is not until I'm on a
sidewalk with a 10 year old girl.
That I understand for the first
time that he is not coming back.
It is the first time I have ever
in my life heard the word abandoned
used to describe what happened to me.
And it is the first time ever that
a human being has ever said to me,
I'm sorry that happened to you.
My friends have said, that sucked.
It was terrible.
Well, I know that my wife.
hates what happened to me as a boy.
But that ten year old girl, she was the
first person to tell me, I am sorry for
what happened to you when you were seven.
When people ask me today why I am still
a public school teacher after 25 years,
with all of the unspeakable, ridiculous,
nonsensical, impossible things.
that schoolteachers go through today,
and with, quite honestly, all the other
opportunities I have to leave a classroom
and go do other things with my life, my
answer is always immediate and simple.
I love kids, but far more important
than that, kids understand me, and they
speak truth to me, and they love me.
Thank you.
Matthew Dicks!